yeah I'm I'm freakin flying an airplane
this is so awesome oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god this is awesome
[Music]
hey Peter what's up that's all I use to
combat seven you love airplanes I do I
like flying games have you played it yet
before I have not
I think the last ace combat game I've
played was to which was 1998 it was an
Ace Combat I played a lot of Cameron
rule was so it was ps2 I think okay well
so the series since then has gone
through some like egg ups and downs I
guess he could say like wasn't the last
one like super microtransaction heavy I
did not know that yeah is that the case
yeah I seem to remember that happening
maybe was like two three years ago which
is why sort of these combat sevens
sounded like such a refreshing change of
pace that's kind of a return to form but
just being a dedicated single player
well maybe not dedicated single player
but really focusing in on that single
player experience and adding VR and you
were telling me some other stuff that
really hasn't been announced yet some
multiplayer yeah I got to play a little
bit of that and you described it as a
battle royale ask ish well that's the
thing is they call it battle royale no
battle royal was the game mode but you
could respawn so it was essentially just
deathmatch okay I'll get into
multiplayer later I think the thing that
I took away was the VR experience was
super cool it was cool but this was
Richard who came with me in film over
here and I'll show you my computer's
frozen here yeah okay this was the
opening what I put the headset on and
listen to what I say I don't get sick
seem to remember you coming back
yesterday and being incapacitated for
about three hours three hours for sure
and the rest of the day this is an
unfortunate lead in into my VR
experience but I can't deny it yeah like
I think the last time I got VR sick this
bad was like two years ago when like
live was out and it was that I forgot
the name of it was a win something but
you would kind of zip around like
spider-man yeah
[Applause]
one more go one more cool Ibrahim just
out the window like it made you so sick
and that lasted the whole day and this
unfortunately like I've never had it
happen until now but how much of that
though is the game like translating what
it would feel like to fly a jet that's a
good point you know cuz like yeah you
felt like crap but I mean how many
videos have you seen of people going up
you know with like a jet pilot and in
the backseat they're great and that's
what you're doing mean you're flying
like jets VR and if it's working well
it's gonna convince you that you're
doing it geez right you can be feeling
geez so like if some guy pushing down on
your shoulders is here it's the other
part which is unfortunate so I did two
missions and you were telling me that no
yeah that there are the game will launch
with three VR missions
I think that's that's it yeah that's it
yeah because you you were expecting it
to be the entire game and I sort of I
said a little bit of you die inside I
told you that definitely but then again
I mean if this is how I'm gonna feel
after every mission then I don't know if
I could do the entire game fair without
actually vomiting but the funny thing is
we had problems with our capture so I so
after I did the two missions was like
taking off the goggles I was like cool
I'm done we saw it wasn't capturing any
of the actual gameplay like all right
I'll just tough out one mission and I
think that's what pushed me over the
edge and incapacitated me the rest of
the day but you had fun though in the
moment was probably one of the coolest
VR experiences I've ever had yeah it's
really cool but I do feel no motion
sickness I someone who like actually has
80 hours of flight time like I was
getting memories of like flying above
the cloud line like looking out and just
feeling the act of flying because you
know if you think about like flying
games most people will prefer a
third-person view right because you can
see more and then you can maybe keep the
horizon line in view right and so far
like any time you are in a first-person
flight game you are still limited right
with your view but in actuality the act
of dogfighting you are focusing on a
target you would like to be ideally
right or else you're just kind of
questioning what
the person is yeah we're you know with
actual footage you need then an arrow to
indicate your target right like yeah you
need context for where you want X and
walk on and so it's someone else at the
event felt the same way where was like
doing that and finding a target and
pulling the act of pulling a plane ready
to view is so exhilarating and honestly
there was there most was like this is
this is evolution
I have lights ins and it was so cool I
had similar feelings when I played Eve
Valkyrie right yeah same so that game
got ruined by its financial model I mean
it was you could like only have one dock
therefore you only have one ship and hit
a pic this is stupid but when I first
played that game the thing that they had
was visual lock-on right so you could be
flying in one direction watch a guy fly
by you and use your gaze to trigger that
yeah and that gave me I think a bit of
what you're describing but definitely
there really was no feeling like it I've
never flown a plane I've obviously never
shot doubt other people play but but
yeah like there's something about doing
that in VR when you have that that range
of movement and visibility that is
that's pretty powerful it was really
convincing it was super powerful and
there were the small additions to with
like being in the cockpit which you know
again it's the unfortunate premise of
showing anyone VR footage it never
translates well unless you're actually
doing it but something about like
looking forward at your mat here and
actually using you're not thinking about
VR you're thinking about Matt Dyle
you're looking at yeah like you're
actually using like the tangible HUD
that's in front of you not just like UI
right like it was it was cool and you
could flip through different scales on
the map and you know even the act of
like switching your your weapon types
here is on the plane like that was super
cool and so I was talking with one of
the PR guys after like I think one of
the reasons why I got so sick was
because essentially like when you're
there and you are experiencing this for
the first time you want to look around
and sip your head around behind you and
see target in actuality you want to you
want to take it easy and like not
overcomplicate things someone else was
saying that like when you got really low
to the ground that's when all these you
know just moving parts of the horizon
and like
your environment and your spinning your
head around like I don't know but that's
what I think you can kind of get that
sickness easy
Oh
but again like that was so cool and then
just you know the act of like emerging
world was like one of when a jet you
should in a jet and like the bits of
that plane like you know you're zipping
through the explosion in the aftermath
of it like you every time it happened I
was flinching
the act of like flying through a
wreckage of a plane okay yes
generates fear that you're gonna wreck
your plane by doing so but you're not
so how did multiplayer go multiplayer
was was okay and it's it's very
different to single-player in my thing
where like single-player you could you
could view it as like you're just an
ultimate badass like taking down planes
walk on it heroes yeah we use your
killing so many planes looking right
granted we it was the first thing we did
at the event was just get I didn't are
flying around so upon getting like
comfortable the game with a single
player I wish we'd done
maybe another round of multiplayer
because one of the core things I feel
like this game is introducing I can't
I'm not positive if it's combat six did
it but it's called a high G turning
which is like you have your acceleration
on the right trigger break if you hold
both down your plane G basically goes
into like a forestall hmm so it's
killing your momentum you're killing
your momentum momentum and you're able
to do basically like pitching and
rolling at really quick speeds so like
you know here's my B wing so it's
actually if this was you chasing me you
could just like if you were good enough
you could just pivot in midair yeah and
like zip your plane around you're
essentially like introducing a
controlled stall we're like you can then
like do cool moves and Pitts around you
lose speed really quickly you need to
recover that's the point though yes yeah
so it it was cool because it felt like
another area to like just get better at
the game like turn use utilize that
because it's kind of like a risk/reward
like you could lose so much speed that
you then get into an unfortunate install
and you need to then dive and someone
could shoot at the sky right like
that haiji maneuverability move
like that kind of steps up this game in
my brain like it introduces a fun
mechanic where the act of dogfighting
can get so boring oh yeah I mean that
that's always kind of the problem with
these games I get so excited about them
and then I get into the scenarios and
it's just lots of passing and close
misses if you think you have them on
target and you write and I always just
figured I was missing out on some of the
skills it would take to maneuver that
space to find an enemy but it always
felt filled to him but I could totally
see how this gee break whatever you want
to call it will totally give that to you
it's got me excited I don't know like
the story seems substantial enough the
cinematics really cool I was not able to
show them but it's it's interesting
enough that I found myself engage it was
like really cool camera working stuff
tech trees I get you met you mentioned
microtransactions I doesn't look like
there will be any that I can tell
Speight there being like a very apparent
tech tree I always get intimidated by
tech trees sometimes because I feel like
of course in a few years like that's a
good way to like slip in like yeah I
mean they could always tell you more
planes and stuff like that I guess we'll
have to wait and see oh yeah oh and all
people are excited for this it's looking
pretty good if you have a psvr be wary
but I don't know should also be excited
for it because I thought it was very fun
[Music]